apogee consists of the following two
primary components apogee services which
are the apis that you use to create
manage and deploy your api proxies also
known as the apigee apis next is the
apigee runtime which is a set of
containerized services in a kubernetes
cluster that google maintains
all your api traffic passes through it
additionally apigee uses other google
cloud services such as identity
management logging analytics metrics and
project management function and then
there are backend services used by your
apps to provide runtime access to data
to get started with setting up your
environment with apigee you can choose
to create an evaluation or a paid
environment in this video i will share
the differences between the two and how
to start off with the evaluation version
which is also known as a test or eval
org
[Music]
before diving into apogee you need to
have a google cloud billing account
created or have management access to
that google cloud project
with that in place you can create an
evaluation org and when you are ready
you can purchase a paid version that
requires a contract with google
now the key differences are the
following
an evaluation org is time limited and
lacks the scalability and flexibility of
production orgs
although an eval org is free of cost you
do need to set up a billing account in
your google cloud project but google
covers your cost and the org is deleted
after 60 days
and finally when using the ui to
provision your eval org you will have
fewer options than if you did so via the
command line
for this video we will walk through how
to create an evaluation org it is very
similar to that of creating a paid org
and in this video's description i have
linked several helpful resources so
let's dive in
creating an apigee evaluation org is
straightforward and can be done using
the ui wizard or command line there's
also a github script for the command
line simplifying that approach let's use
the wizard since this is the simplest
and quickest which is in the docs
first i enter the name of my project or
i can choose to create a new one
note that the wizard detects that it is
not a project with paid entitlements and
can only be used for evaluation
next click the edit icon next to apis
and choose enable apis this takes a
couple of minutes to complete
a check will display next to the enable
api step and the networking step will be
available
click edit next to networking the setup
networking pane is then displayed
select a network from the authorized
network drop-down list
for most eval orgs you select the
network that google cloud created when
you created your google cloud project
called default however if you have a
custom network and peering range you
want to use select it from the list
for this example i will choose default
connect
next i will select the option
automatically allocate ip range but if
you already have one or wish to create
one yourself you can select the desired
option from the drop down the ip range
is for peering between your google cloud
project and apigee and the process also
takes a couple of minutes to complete
now that networking is configured we can
provision the org select the analytics
and runtime regions closest to you
click provision
this can take anywhere from 20 to 30
minutes
once the organization has been
provisioned you will get an email
notification your apigee evaluation is
ready to use
let's go back to the wizard and move on
to configuring access routing this
allows you to configure access to your
apigee endpoint either internally or
externally
internal limits access to the apigee
endpoint to vms in your gcp project this
is the internal load balancer
external allows access to your apis over
the public internet through the
configuration of an http global load
balancer with a public static ip address
creating an external load balancer can
incur fees for up to 20 to 25 dollars in
your project which can be covered by the
free project credits i linked again in
the description for this example i will
choose the external option which is
called enable internet access
you now have the option to configure the
hostname if you have access to a dns
registry and have an existing domain you
can enter your own hostname and then
create a new dns record for your hosting
pointing to the static ip address
if you do not have a hostname you can
use a wildcard dns service such as
nip.io which is suggested
it will give you a hostname using the
external ip address of the global load
balancer with the domain suffix nip.io
with this approach google automatically
provisions and manages the ssl
certificates for the global load
balancer this is the easiest and
quickest path to getting your org
operational
and here's what that would look like
when finished
alternatively you can specify your own
hostname from a domain you own i have
entered mine which becomes the hostname
for my apis
this also shows us the runtime location
and the internal load balancer for the
apigee endpoint it's now asking for a
subnet and i can choose an option in the
drop down which in this case is called
default and is in the same region as the
runtime
i then have the option to use my own ssl
certificates and key or i can skip this
by leaving it blank and have google
create and manage them automatically
this is the easiest
then select set access
note this step can take about 10 minutes
to complete
in this step you can see the progress of
each component being created
upon completion choose continue
here we can see that apigee has provided
the ip address of the global load
balancer which i now use to create an
entry in my dns configuration so let's
go ahead and do that
in this example our domain is hosted on
google domains here i create a new
custom record using the prefix
of type a
and add the ip address then click save
this will take about 10 minutes to
propagate on google domains but may vary
depending on your domain host
once that happens i can choose launch to
see the hello guest response from the
hello world proxy that apigee created
for us
great now we can go to the apigee
console and begin creating our own
proxies which we have a video for you to
reference as a next step
and there you have it a quick
walkthrough on how to create your first
evaluation org in apigee using the
wizard interface
and friends if you found this episode
helpful you can click like or subscribe
to the channel for more content like
this cheers
[Music]
you